wie viel outakes haben
wir ja dieses Jahr eine riesige
Herausforderung und das war so für mich
einfach schön um mal loszulassen und zu
sagen ich lerne einfach was neues auch
danach war mein Team einfach so
geplätet da schießen wir jetzt noch die
Tränen in die Augen da braucht ihr
Taschentücher weil ihr Tränen lachen
werdet muss ich mich kurz ausweinen und
hab ich okay sammel dich einfach
[Musik]
wieder
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallyis
Welt herzlich willkommen zu meinem
diesjährigen Jahresrückblick der
Jahresrückblick
2023 in diesem Video wollen wir einfach
noch mal aufs Jahr zurückblicken das
Jahr 23 wird so bei mir persönlich
tatsächlich sehr in die Geschichte
eingehen das Jahr 23 war voller
Ereignisse positiv als auch negativ aber
das Positive muss ich sagen überwiegt ja
trotzdem immer ist ja immer so dass ich
eher die Einstellung habe das Glas ist
halb voll statt halb leer ja
geschäftlich muss man sagen war dieses
Jahr sehr
emotional sehr positiv es gab so viele
Ereignisse und ich würde einfach jetzt
sagen wir starten chronologisch durch
beim Anfang des Jahres gut der
jahresrückblig letztes Jahr hat ja so
ein bisschen inspir
Interpretationsspielraum gelassen wir
haben letztes ja schon bisschen
eigentlich angeteasert wie die einfach
das so schnell so krass aufgesogen hat
und den Tanz einfach konnte es sie hat
nicht mal einmal geprobt und dann konnst
du es die Frau muss aber es wundert mich
eigentlich wundert es mich nicht aber ne
jedes Mal bin ich trotzdem wieder muss
mehr tanzen oh natürlich wussten wir zu
dem Zeitpunkt schon dass ich bei Let
Dance mitmachen werde meine let
dancezeit muss ich sagen habe ich
vorbereitet indem ich ganz viele
rezeptvideos vorgedreht habe und wir
haben wirklich Wochen Monate damit
verbracht auch an Wochenenden zu drehen
damit ich wenn ich bei Let's Dance in
der Fernsehsendung bin den Kopf frei
habe und wirklich mich aufs Tanzen
fokussieren kann und bis heute muss ich
sagen ich habe mich auf diese Zeit
richtig gefreut weil ich wusste für mich
wird's einfach mal so eine Zeit in der
ich einfach was für mich tu ich bin ja m
als Tochter einer Großfamilie groß
geworden fünf Kinder und habe war auf
der Schule dann habe ich Abitur gemacht
dann habe ich Murat kennengelernt dann
wir geheiratet dann habe ich Kinder
gekriegt ich habe studiert ich habe das
you
den YouTube-Kanal aufgebaut dann habe
ich direkt immer angefangen zu arbeiten
und es war halt immer so immer alles
schön aber ich hatte tatsächlich so noch
nie in meinem Leben einfach nur mal Zeit
für mich so fern ab vom Mutter sein oder
vom Unternehmertum oder vom arbeiten
oder so von allem und es war für mich
einfach eine Zeit wo ich wusste jede
Woche werde ich genießen und jede Woche
ist einfach für mich eine große
Herausforderung denn bis dahin war ich
der richtige Sportmuffel ich habe es
auch einfach gehasst zu
schwitzen immer wenn es anstrengend
wurde wie aufgehört früher und dann kam
so die letzte dancezeit und ich war muss
ich sagen ich habe mich einfach nur
drauf gefreut was Neues zu lernen das
war schon krass und am Anfang war ich
bisschen aufgeregt was was sagt die was
sagen meine Eltern dazu was sagt die
Familie was sagt die Community aber im
Endeffekt war es mir eigentlich auch
völlig egal wer was sagt denn ich habe
für mich entschieden es wird was richtig
tolles und ich habe mir gedacht ich
mache das jetzt einfach und es war
einfach das Beste was ich hätte tun
können ich hatte auch so mit Massimo den
besten Tanzpartner zur Seite der einfach
mega professionell ist und es war
einfach jede Woche eine schöne
Herausforderung ich habe jede Woche was
neues gelernt auch so über mich und das
war so für mich einfach schön um mal
loszulassen und zu sagen ich lass mich
da jetzt mitreiben und ich lerne einfach
was neues und alleine die ganzen
Schrittfolgen die die Technik die
Emotion dazu das war nicht so einfach
für mich da auch loszulassen ich habe
bis heute noch nicht so ganz realisiert
dass ich da mitgemacht habe und ich habe
mir bis heute die Sendungen nicht
angeschaut und mein
Ausstieg kam für mich sehr plötzlich und
ich war richtig traurig weil ich gerade
so angekommen bin und so das so geliebt
habe einfach was Neues zu machen und ich
mit dachte wah jetzt jetzt packt mich
auch der Ehrgeiz aber ich wusste dass
viele andere viel besser tanzen können
als ich aber es war einfach es war
richtig schön es war richtig schön ich
habe viel über mich gelernt ich habe
gelernt Sport kann Spaß machen ab 30
brauchst du sport in deinem
Leben und man kann immer was neues
lernen egal ob man sich es zutraut oder
nicht in meinem privaten Umfeld kann ich
euch sagen wer mein aller allergrößter
Unterstützer
war jetzt haltet euch fest das war mein
Papa mein Papa und meine Mama und da
schießen mir jetzt noch die Tränen in
die Augen die waren so stolz auf mich
der hat gesagt das habt ihr so toll
gemacht ich habe früher auch volklore
getanzt und deswegen war das nie ein
Problem dass dann Frau und Mann zusammen
tanzen mein Papa sieht es auch ganz
anders obwohl er so wahnsinnig
traditionell türkisch ist und ich hätte
mich so sehr gefreut und deswegen war
ich da auch so traurig weil ich mir
dachte ich hät Mama und Papa einfach
gern dabei gehabt mal live und als ich
dann raus war da war ich so traurig weil
so die Zeit so plötzlich vorbei war von
heute auf morgen ja dann sagte mein Papa
zu mir chrissem also meine Tochter ich
bin so stolz auf Dich dass Du mit Deinen
35 Jahren noch so toll tanzen gelernt
hast und der hat so geweint der hat
gesagt das hat ihm so Spaß gemacht jede
Woche zuzuschauen aber sie waren richtig
stolz und die haben mich wirklich von
Anfang bis Ende einfach unterstützt und
haben mir immer Mutz gesprochen und
haben gesagt dass ich mich das getraut
hab das zu tanzen das war richtig schön
ja das heißt wir sind tanzend ins Jahr
gestartet und mir war da einfach wichtig
dass während der kompletten Zeit in der
ich tanzen war keiner hat sagen können
jetzt vernachlässigt Sie hier Ihre
Rezepte und ihr Team habe ich nämlich
nicht gemacht wie gesagt alles super
vorbereitet und in diesem Jahr gingen
einfach über 300 Rezepte online ja das
Jahr hat 365 Tage und wir haben über 300
Rezepte hochgeladen und das ist schon
muss ich sagen echtter wahnsinn ich
meine Plattformen haben sich ja auch
verändert und ich habe hier lange Videos
hochgeladen ich habe Shorts und res
hochgeladen ich habe richtig viel
gekocht richtig viel gebacken ab und zu
noch do yourself gemacht und das ist
schon muss ich sagen richtig viel und
auch im neuen Jahr gibt's natürlich
weiterhin ganz tolle Rezepte von mir
denn es gibt auch bis heute noch vieles
dass ich noch nicht ausprobiert habe
also seid da gespannt und freut euch
einfach auf neue Rezepte und wenn ihr
egal wann rezeptwünsche habt einfach
immer in die Kommentare schreiben denn
nach wie vor lese ich einfach total
viele Kommentare ich beantworte viele
Kommentare und ich reagiere auch auf
viele Kommentare deswegen Haut da
einfach immer alles rein denn der Kanal
lebt immer nur von eurem Feedback von
euren Bewertungen wenn ihr den Kanal
abonniert und auch teilt mit euren
Freunden schreibt mir einfach immer
alles das ist richtig schön mein Team
freut sich ich freue mich und alles
Feedback was ich zum Kanal bekomme sei
Kritik oder auch Lob gebe ich wirklich
immer ans Team weiter und die freuen
sich nur so können wir uns verbessern
nur so können wir uns weiterentwickeln
und das ist dann immer richtig schön ja
dann ist nicht so wir werden wir was
machen und keiner schaut sondern wir
wissen dann ihr schaut zu und ihr habt
Wünsche Ideen Anregungen und dann
erfüllen wir die eben auch ja dann war
das erste große Ereignis tatsächlich im
sicon
der PL
[Musik]
day hab so das erste Mal für unsere
Gäste und Zuschauer die Tore
geöffnet ich war tatsächlich nur am
zweiten Tag zur Hälfte mit dabei weil es
ja noch so die letztezeit war und wir
gesagt haben wir planen den PL einfach
jetzt mal ohne meine Anwesenheit weil
wir auch nicht wussten bin ich noch drin
bin ich nicht drin und dann war das ein
sehr emotionales Wochenende muss ich
sagen es war so kurz nach dem Ausstieg
da war ich emotional noch nicht so ganz
auf der Spur hab so bisschen gebraucht
zum Verarbeiten aber es war richtig cool
und wir werden im nächsten Jahr das
nicht in dieser Art und Weise machen
aber wir werden uns was tolles anderes
überlegen da könnte einfach mal gespannt
sein aber nach wie vor gibt's ja meinen
Shop in Mannheim den ihr besuchen könnt
wo ich auch immer mal wieder
Ankündigungen mache Events mache oder
auch mit Gästen mal dort bin wie z.B vor
kurzem auch mit DIK dem singenden
Nashorn er war mit mir dort wir haben
gemeinsam Plätzchen gebacken haben eine
tolle Sendung gedreht und da ist ja auch
eigentlich so so ist auch die Grundidee
entstanden damals mit meinem Shop wir
haben den ja 2020 eröffnen wollen dann
kam Corona dann kam so die pandemiezeit
und so der Ursprungsplan mit dass die
Küche dort aussieht wie bei mir im
Studio und wir haben dort zwei Herde und
wir können dort mit meinen Gästen
zubereiten und Zuschauer können dazu
kommen das haben wir so in der Art gar
nicht machen können weil Pandemie
bedingt einfach viele Regelungen es
nicht zugelassen haben aber auch das
wollen wir machen ich möchte öfter
wieder in den Shop wir möchten dort
Ereignisse und Events machen dass ihr
uns alle besuchen könnt das heißt alle
die mal ins sellis Welt eintauchen
wollen sind immer herzlich dazu
eingeladen nach Mannheim in den Shop zu
kommen mein Team ist ein wahnsinnig
tolles Team egal ob Mannheim wheusel
oder auch Suls am Necker ich habe über
die letzten Jahre einfach in Team
zusammengebaut ist echt Wahnsinn was
hier für einen Zusammenhalt ist was hier
für motivierte kreative inspirierende
Menschen arbeiten die einfach alle mit
Herzblut dabei sind wir haben auch viel
Kontakt zu Menschen die nicht mal hier
arbeiten die aber nach wie vor SIS Welt
lieben und mein Team lieben und mit
denen wir uns auch immer wieder treffen
also ist echt richtig schön 3 2
1 ich bin ganz froh dass ich so ein
tolles Team habe was einfach so toll
zusammenhält in guten und auch in
schwierigen Zeiten muss man sagen eine
ganz großes Ereignis auch emotional war
für uns der Tag an dem ich hier m ein
Event gemacht habe für den Bundesverband
Kinderhospiz da bin ich ja Botschafterin
seit einigen Jahren und unterstütz gerne
den Bundesverband kinderhausbeats es
zeigt einfach dass es leider leider
viele Kinder und Jugendliche gibt die
niemals erwachsen werden und der
Bundesverband kinderspats organisiert
immer gerne Events für die Kinder und
deren Familien für Geschwisterkinder und
da sind wir einfach super gerne mit
dabei und dieses Jahr weil ich nicht im
Europapark sein konnte zum hospiztag
habe ich gesagt machen wir hier mal
einen richtig schönen Tag im Valley und
die Kinder durften hier miterleben wie
Videos entstehen wie Fotos entstehen wir
haben gemeinsam gebacken und es war
einfach richtig schöner Tag und auch
danach war mein Team einfach so geplätet
von den ganzen Emotionen alle die hier
waren waren einfach nur begeistert es
war sehr ja es hat einen schon sehr
mitgenommen weil es für mich oder für
alle nach wie vor ganz schlimm ist wenn
man sieht dass es einfach Menschen gibt
die unheilbar krank sind und gerade wenn
es Kinder sind nimmt es einen natürlich
noch mehr mit aber wenn man dann weiß
dass man einen schönen Tag machen kann
und ihnen eine Freude ins Gesicht
zaubern kann dann ist es einfach eine
richtig schöne Sache aber das sind dann
so Momente für mich da ähm das weiß ich
noch da stand ich im Büro und ich habe
gewusst okay gleich geht's los dann
musste ich mich kurz ausweinen und D
habe ich g okay sammel dich einfach
wieder
weil die Kinder werden hier Spaß haben
und du motivierst sie du machst sie
glücklich und dann haben wir das halt
auch gemacht das war echt schön aber
eigentlich zerreiß dir innerlich so das
Herz weil wenn ich könnte würde ich auf
den Knopf drücken und wird einfach alle
Kinder heilen und den Schmerz der
Familien einfach wegnehmen aber das geht
leider nicht ja und das sind so Momente
für mich wo ich einfach immer weiß und
das trage ich immer in mir egal was
passiert in meinem Leben und egal was so
irgendwie passiert bin ich einfach froh
dass wir alle gesund sind und es kann
einen immer schlimmer treffen und
deswegen habe ich so eine grundpositive
Einstellung egal was passiert auch wenn
es dir den Boden unter den Füßen
wegzieht ähm und egal was dich so privat
belastet bin ich immer der Meinung es
kann noch schlimmer kommen und man
sollte immer dankbar sein für das was
man hat für das was man erreicht hat für
die Menschen die um einen herum sind ich
bin einfach der Meinung dass wenn ich
morgens aufstehe mit einem Lächeln im
Gesicht auch wenn es mir manchmal schwer
fällt dann packe ich die Playlist aus
und dann lache ich einfach in den
Spiegel und dann geht's mir einfach
schon besser man kann nicht alle sorgen
damit wegbekommen und nicht alle
Probleme lösen aber da ich zwei Kinder
habe für die ich immer gerne stark bin
auch wenn ich Ihnen mal gerne schwache
Momente zeige und sage es ist auch in
Ordnung ist es nach wie vor wichtig ich
trage eine große Verantwortung ich habe
ein riesen Team um mich herum und alle
hängen so bisschen natürlich auch an mir
und hängen daran dass ich eben auch
stark bin und stark bleibe und deswegen
ja kam für viele vielleicht auch so das
Thema Trennung etwas spontan und etwas
plötzlich aber wie gesagt ich bin da
ich will jetzt nicht sagen gut drin
Dinge wegzulächeln aber ich kann halt
ganz gut dann so das private abtrennen
und das Geschäftliche weil ich einfach
weiß dass es wichtig ist ja das wollte
ich mal sagen dann war dieses Jahr eine
riesige
Herausforderung also die war wirklich da
habe ich kurz gedacht das erste Mal
scheiterst du jetzt so richtig richtig
an dieser
Riesentorte of the Socials da habe ich
mir mal also wie wie schwer war die
Torte 49 kg gefühlt 8 m hoch battle of
the Socials war ein riesen Event in
Mainz und ich habe hier eine Torte
gebacken für dieses Event und es war
einfach der Wahnsinn das war wow wie
viel Kilo teigcreme Fondant also das ist
die größte fondantplatte die ich je mit
eigener Kraft ausgerollt habe ich will
es mal nur sagen die hat ein Durchmesser
von über ein
Meter das war schon Wahnsinn aber es ist
geglückt es war ein super Event wir
haben ganz viele Creator getroffen war
ein super Spiel und es war richtig cool
ich war aber auch zu Gast in vielen
anderen Formaten wie z.B und da bin ich
heute noch aufgeregt wenn ich drüber
nachdenke ich war bei Jan bömermann bei
böm brutzelt war eingeladen und durfte
mit ihm Kochen und Backen war richtig
genial ich war bei Kurt Krömer im
Podcast war auch richtig schön war
einfach mal schön so zu Gast in anderen
Formaten zu sein weil man so auch
Menschen einfach anders kennenlernt und
das einfach was richtig richtig schönes
war ja dann war ich noch bei Terra X das
war so glaube ich auch das erste Mal
dass ich als Expertin gut ich war früher
mal immer bei Galileo aber so das erste
mal so als Expertin fürs Thema Gewürze
im Fernsehen war bei d Dalli war ich z
gar war auch eine richtig tolle Sendung
weil ich meine di Dalli kennt man so von
früher ich zwar nicht da bin ich
wirklich zu jung dafür
aber meine Eltern kennen das natürlich
und die waren richtig stolz dass ich da
eingeladen war ja und dann hatte ich
natürlich auch noch einige Gäste da bei
mir ich hatte zum einen die Liebe anida
von babyg Business dicker war z Gast tim
benco war zu
Gast
atemlos durch die Nacht sie was Max
gesinger mit uns ma Blümchen war auch zu
Gast aber da seht ihr die Folge erst im
neuen Jahr ansonsten war sopia Thel bei
mir zu Gast und Sophia kenne ich schon
richtig lange und zwar richtig lustig
mit ihr auch da gibt's dann die Folge zu
Gast bei Sally mit Sophia teel jetzt im
neuen Jahr und ich kann nur sagen also
da da braucht ihr Taschentücher weil ihr
Tränen lachen werdet ihr werdet Tränen
lachen diese Frau ist einfach sowas von
lustig und die Kombi die war einfach nur
genial malwanne war auch endlich da
malwanne war da in meiner Küche und die
Kombination aus uns beiden gefällt mir
auch richtig gut das kommt auch auf euch
zu und dann habe ich in dies Jahr
tatsächlich einfach unendlich viele
Küchen geplant für pimp my kitchen pimp
my kitchen ist ja so ein Format in dem
ich entweder pommis oder auch jemanden
von euch oder aus dem Freundes und
Bekanntenkreis mit einer Küche
überrasche und diese Küchen also ich
stehe immer vor einer anderen
Herausforderung mal ist es eine Küche
für eine Familie mal für ein Single mal
muss es die und die besondere
Eigenschaft haben großer Raum kleiner
Raum so jede Küche hat ja an sich
Herausforderungen und das dann immer
funktional schön gemütlich praktisch zu
gestalten ist nicht so einfach und
Küchen habe ich richtig viele geplant
und die kommen jetzt auch demnächst alle
online also wir haben wir richtig
richtig viel küchencontent der noch
ausgestrahlt wird und da könnt ihr euch
wirklich freuen auf ganz ganz viele
tolle nobilia Küchen einfach so diese
Vielfalt auch zu sehen ich bin ja jedes
Jahr auf der Hausmesse und jedes Jahr
könnte man sagen okay alte Küche raus
neue Küche rein weil jedes Jahr was noch
schöneres kommt aber es sind Küchen und
keine Hosen die man je jeden Tag
wechseln kann von daher ist es aber
schön für mich dass ich immer ganz
individuelle neue richtig schöne Küchen
planen kann das freut mich jedes Mal das
ist echt schön das für mich so da habe
ich mich auch so gefunden in demem
Gebiet was jetzt nicht unbedingt kochen
backen ist aber trotzdem noch mit Kochen
Backen zu tun hat und wo ich mich und
meinen inneren Monk einfach ausleben
kann würde ich jetzt mal sagen mein
neues Studio ist ja jetzt auch fertig
geplant und gebaut ebenso unser
Hauswirtschaftsraum und die schöne
Familienküche auch diese Videos werden
im neuen Jahr jetzt
folgen da ist es einfach so dass jetzt
natürlich privat vieles dazwischen kam
und ich eigentlich jetzt im Dezember
zwei Küchen ausstrahlen wollte aber da
gingen jetzt einfach andere Dinge vor
und alles ist vorbereitet und ich möchte
natürlich wenn ich küchenvideos mache
die auch perfekt ausstrahlen das heißt
die Küche muss perfekt einsortiert sein
die muss schon fertig etikettiert sein
und da nehme ich mir gerne die Zeit
dafür und mach das halt auch sel
und da kommt richtig viel online aber
ich habe mir gedacht ich Spalte das so
ein bisschen auf damit es nicht so ein
ewig langes Video wird mache ich einmal
eine room Tour durchs neue Studio und
dann würde ich noch mal gezielt sagen
Küchenorganisation und wenn ihr da
fragen habt Anregungen Tipps schreibt
sie gerne in die Kommentare dann kann
ich das noch aufgreifen denn auch das
werde ich alles jetzt nach dem
Weihnachtsurlaub im neuen Jahr alles für
euch abdrehen und dann wirklich auf eure
individuellen Wünsche eingehen ja aber
neue Studio das ist das richtig schön da
fühle ich mich richtig wohl es ist alles
hell es ist weiblicher aber trotzdem
nicht zu mädchenhaft es ist so ein
richtig schöner Raum geworden zum
Wohlfühlen ist ist wirklich also ja da
werden wir hoffentlich viele viele tolle
Stunden drin verbringen und viele viele
tolle Videos für euch mit euch drehen ja
freue ich mich drauf SIS Welt W SIS
Welt wenn ich auch so ein paar
unveröffentlichte Szenen hätten wie viel
Outtakes haben
wir
ja die
laülle dass wir noch sympathischer
werden als wir eh schon sind sympathisch
Barten würtenberg
mittig aber ich habe mir irgendwann
diese ke Pflaume Laacher angewöhnt
[Gelächter]
dieses findest du wir haben genug pink
in der Küche nee nee ne fehlt noch hallo
Peter
Butter ich bin doch keine Maschine ich
bin ein Mensch aus Fleisch und Blut und
ich will backen bis zum letzten
Atemzug
if happy
know also falls ich schon gesagt habe
sorry dann Schneid halt raus
hungry feet ich hoffe ihr habt eure
Business Unterhose
dabei heute schon Gemüse
gegessen jetzt gibt's Schnecke und wer
kann am beste Schnecke checke ich habe
gehört gibt
Schnecke
und
Sandwich ah B schon wieder
soweit ready NPE ready
ja falls die Kamera wackelt anna hat
keinen Anfall oder so Anna muss nur
lachen aber die sind dann hoppala jetzt
fällt die Kamera hier zusammen Anna was
ist denn da los ich kann nicht mehr ich
kann so nicht arbeiten J das Ende wir
hatten hier wieder einen großen Dreh mit
Bosch mit dem Team von punchin das war
richtig schön ist auch immer ein
lustiger Dreh weil auch da ich so
bisschen die Verantwortung ans Team
abgeben kann und trotzdem viele viele
technische Dinge erkläre die so die
Geräte mit sich bringen aber immer
lustiger Dreh freue ich mich immer
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
drauf i know that
weve like Alp
[Musik]
om nice
danke schön und dann habe ich noch was
richtig Neues gewagt denn ich war auch
zu Gast in einer Serie bei Alles was
zählt da durfte ich mich selbst spielen
das war auch richtig cool weil ich so
das erste Mal bei einem seriendreh mit
dabei war und falls ihr das nicht
gesehen habt könnt ihr auch gerne bei
Attl plus noch mal reinschauen es ist
die Folge vom
27.12 ich meine auch 28 und
29.12 könnt ihr gerne mal reinschauen ja
und ansonsten freue ich mich aufs Neue
Jahr mit vielen tollen Rezeptideen mit
vielen tollen neuen Formaten mit zu Gast
bei sallyi falls ihr da Wünsche habt wer
hier mal zu Gast sein soll gerne in die
Kommentare schreiben küchefrei haben wir
als neues Format entwickelt was auch
ziemlich cool ist wo wir jetzt schon
einige Gäste auf unserer Liste haben die
noch kommen werden dann werden wieder
weitere küchenvideos folgen wir hatten
auch richtig viel Spaß immer mit unseren
musikreels W ab und zu bisschen
ausflippen warum auch nett ich will ich
will ich will fliegen wie bei Marvel zum
frühstückapes und dery
[Musik]
L und dann werden wir einfach mal
schauen was das neue Jahr so mit sich
bringt ich meine rein kreativ und so s
teammäßig war das Jahr richtig cool war
richtig toll privat ist natürlich vieles
vorgefallen und W müssen wir uns jetzt
umstrukturieren aber auch diese
Herausforderung werden wir meistern und
auch mir geht's ab und zu nicht so gut
und auch ich bin mal down und auch ich
zweifel an mir und auch ich bin mal
traurig aber das sind alles Dinge die
ich gar nicht so auf meinen Plattformen
ausspielen möchte denn nach wie vor ist
es alles privat und Familiensache
und ich kann einfach nur sagen dass ich
froh bin dass ich wundervolle Menschen
um mich herum habe die mich auffangen
die wissen wie ich bin die
ähm ja die einfach für mich da sind mich
unterstützen mir beistehen und das weiß
ich auch dass ich eine ganz tolle
Community habe die mir immer beisteht
und
die ja gar nicht so viel drauf geben was
so drumherum gesagt wird oder
interpretiert oder spekuliert wird und
deswegen freue ich mich auf ein neues
Jahr und
ja freue mich auf weiterhin eine richtig
schöne Zeit mit euch das Jahr 2024 wird
bestimmt noch einige Überraschungen mit
sich bringen und ich freue mich drauf
ich bin ein sehr offener Mensch ich
freue mich immer auf Veränderungen ich
freue mich aber auch auf Traditionen die
wir fortführen können und deswegen
bleibt einfach gespannt bleibt uns treu
und mach schon noch was zu sagen oder
schl du schon mein Schatz ich w sagen
ich wünsche euch alles Gute fürs neue
Jahr und vielleicht noch als
Abschlusssatz würde ich euch einfach
gerne mitgeben
egal in was für Situationen ihr steckt
und egal wie schwer es auch mal zu sein
scheint lasst euch niemals eure
Lebensfreude nehmen und lasst niemals zu
dass irgendjemand oder irgendetwas auf
dieser Welt euch das Strahlen nimmt und
die Sonne in euch verschwinden lässt
also alles Liebe und Gute fürs neue Jahr
bis bald
mein kleines BAB wie kann man so süß
sein
a
Schatzi me
BAB